all right then we are live slash pointy
boxes what's going on oh no it's another
week apparently a new membership at
Bungie felt like being punctual on his
first official this week at Bungie sells
up a little earlier than usual but yeah
got a couple things to talk about might
be a little flashy err in speed but
we've definitely got some things to
cover so sorry but unless you actually
say it a flash might actually live up to
the day like we're gonna do that I'm not
gonna hold my breath for sure we don't
have well it was an awesome special
guest it should be a little more focused
this week
absolutely shout out to Doc amnesia that
was a great us article waiting on that
next one boy you got you got the
Internet in storm well we got some uh
some blob of business to talk about so
what's going on man well I mean we got
this week at Bungie came out a little
mini update there so DM go4 I think his
name is Dylan is that correct yes yep so
he is now officially another community
manager there at Bungie so they've got
Cosmo deej and now Dylan so nice little
group they've got and they've got a lot
of people to manage so the ages sounded
like he's a little more in the
background you know kind of be in the
puppet master with a couple things but I
talked to probably the team's more as
these guys a little more you know player
facing so kind of nice more people in
Bungie still doing their thing of you
know somebody who from work their butt
off and had a passion for it and they
brought him in so that's actually really
really cool yeah man it's really cool
and I think that um just on the help
standpoint you know anything to kind of
get you know I kind of feel fatigue
right now like going you know during the
like you know this is I guess we could
sit at this - Dark Ages it feels like a
little dark destiny one all over again
in the beginning right around the dark
below dlc people you know community was
upset so I know sometimes he may get a
lot of unnecessary trio
yeah yeah it's not necessary as much as
hard as they were cuz like hey nobody's
perfect and so many people have to
answer to people that they don't get to
talk forward and they have to speak the
message that's told to them so exactly
the messenger you can yeah until we know
where all the answers and things happen
which we never will just you know be
constructive with the criticism out
there just keep it clean
absolutely so it's always good to see
that those they're beefing up you know
community manages to help out
Cosmo help out teach and uh yeah I've
got number positives you know to say
about um damage Oh for so let's get into
these uh going on with the flaw what's
what's going on so this week February
22nd the faction rally is live going on
right now so future will Carl is trying
to win one but sadly they keep getting
the who say the shaft of the weapon
Department they don't have the bling
going on either but I mean you could at
least give them a solid weapon with like
you know an awesome perk as opposed to
what seemed like the weakest of the
three so being rubbing between monarchy
and dead orbit but I think new monarch
you might pull it out again just because
somebody are on there with a little perk
picking whoever gets to pick the perk
buttons like I'm gonna make new monarch
you the best one once again somebody out
there pulling strings that I completely
agree there's some puppet master stuff
going on right now there's no doubt
about it
it is nice they did fix the the patch is
in effect now so as many lost sectors as
you can loot you'll get them so I know
some people were just running around the
tras land with those three cloaks quick
ones together kind of running those in a
circle people are doing that one thing
that I was actually I was just streaming
one night or something I was kind of
wondering I would I really wish
bungie.net would have like a make
faction or Ally's feel a little more a
little more weight to them have an
ongoing total for all three so yes I
would love to see that live to be like
oh crap like hey let me go jump on my
little character if I want this to win
because you know just casually playing
on one whoever his new monarchy but I
want future Oracle to go switch like if
you don't know then nobody has any
incentive even at least today for this
week at bunch you could put an update at
least in here if it's not a running
total you're like hey this is what we're
looking at for now this is the points as
much data as Bungie has you
no they have that information absolutely
listen yeah as data-driven as they are
it's sitting somewhere somebody knows
that do I agree I agree it would
definitely add a little bit more
intensity to it you know and like I was
thinking to is like a we had talked
before in the past like you know I just
miss also the grind I look I don't mind
that they're doing it it's kind of a
limited time event but at the same time
I also want like like right now there
was no incentive for me to really play
this week thanks Ryan I love fashion
rally just because you know I had all
the ornaments and stuff already for new
marquee you know me so I'm just like
okay I wish there was like old school d1
member we talked about you know last
flash playing well we could kind of
grind towards maybe like you know even
if it's an emblem or you know when you
get to it like just leveling up you know
I can level up had a Oh
and get something either whether like
either be like a class item you know a
ghost or like a you know some type of
special emblem kind of signifying you
know you court your grind your
commitment to the factional it's a
little bit more yeah they still need
weight to them it's like the idea of the
factions because cool but you know they
can ever put like PvP in the open spaces
and actually kind of have it that way
it's like it'd be interesting to be like
working on a public event or something
and have a whole crew roll up but that
rolls into like you know groups of six
going into patrols and stuff out there
for crazy but I mean yeah I'm kind of
with you they just don't do a ton for me
again most of it still especially
cosmetics it's another set of armor
where the stats don't mean too much so
for me it's like you know it's it's a
step they fix the patch but you know
just something simple as an ongoing
tally it would be kind of interesting
and maybe that's one of those things
where they're afraid of showing the
numbers like I mean we've never seen it
so at this point it probably be the best
under show numbers because even if it's
low we have no idea so yeah absolutely
fair enough but yeah we'll see who wins
next week of course but the big info
dropped yesterday actually
so right here for the development
roadmap so coming next week on the 27th
we've got patch one point one point
three so your February patch couple
changes have happened as most would
probably anticipate things were pushed a
little farther out just
make sure biggest thing they're saying
is when they release anything at this
point they want it to be up to a high
quality and I appreciate that I said
that about like you know whatever taking
king 2.0 is like take as long as you
need to do it right I mean I know some
people are gonna have a big weight but
if you wait and then do a large
publicity with something that is
actually fixed that's gonna be a lot
better received then you know hey let's
try this knife while scoring well the
scoring is broken somebody got a million
points and I got four like please don't
have something like that so absolutely
and you've been preaching this you've
been preaching this evanka this has been
your model you've been very consistent
every flashpoint rallies you always tell
me like I'm you know hot oh I'd rather
wait and they get it right and if it
means delaying content please do so
although I'm sad that you know some
things that push back yeah kind of
- a big one but go alright but yeah if
you want to run down then I'll let you
lead the bullets here and jump in yeah
man I mean right now so it's looking
like we're talking about the gonna start
with the season the actual bullet for
uh-oh what you call it off February 27th
one point one point three yep so
nightfall scoring in high scoring
tracking which is cool you know I'm
definitely a fan of that you know
obviously I mean you know sure Rock
strike from d1 with my absolute favorite
so to see that come to the nightfall and
still time is gonna be a factor we just
got so that that's cool the destined
destination emblem variance looks like
those wearing stuff we're gonna looks
like a deep dive as we go down a little
bit longer in the update
you know we're get into that
specifically so you know well deep dive
but on fire team members destinies on
the destination map however quality life
just that it happens exactly
I like that you know all about that
that's a huge one just it just shows
life on the map right just shows
activity on a minute be nice if it was
like if they could even add a little
more it's like in an instance or
something I know switch between them but
if they're not even in a fireteam hey
say there's somebody running around
doing this like a public event and you
see them say there's something real like
eight you want to join my you know fire
team if you're running with one or two
make it an option to show like hey your
fire teams in green but you can see
other people in blue
just you know out in your instance you
know have somebody and then start
running public events yep you know no
there so it's a step but again we could
always we always seem to want more and I
know that's literally like that's
probably the epitome of all of destiny
we never have enough we never have
enough content we never have enough
things fixed fast enough we always want
more weapons more things like we always
want more but these are things if they
want the message of the game to be a
team play with a team play with
absolutely kind of a way to help with
that so absolutely it creates engagement
and you want people to say oh look at
that Guardian over the hill he needs
some help he's on my map I see his
gamertag or whatever it may be
you don't I mean it's ID and you just
just make that process interaction you
know more seamless and I think with the
map this is like the beginning stages we
see in our fireteam
let's see step exact now let's next step
for let's shoot for a goal of whoever's
in that instance you know I mean or
maybe maybe a party there maybe next
step is clan then maybe third step is
instance yeah he's exactly yeah I mean
if you look and you're like hey or the
clan if you look on the director and you
you know hover over crucible you see
that a couple people in there you get a
few in the raid you can see where your
clan members at and be like hey do I
want to go try and join somebody right
now so absolutely yes sounds pretty cool
and then we got a PC public text check I
know you're happy boxes yeah I mean it's
just PC gamers you just straight up have
to have it so I'm glad to see this in
there and it's it's an opt-in thing
which is nice because I mean if you
played World of Warcraft you'd go into
town and you just get spammed like crazy
you could leave it but I mean if you
ever needed to find somebody it was nice
they're never gonna be there's not gonna
be you know 150 people running around in
a tower it's never gonna be that much
you might have 25 people so it should be
reasonable on that front I think it'll
actually probably be a good thing
overall though absolutely man and then
we have I'm trying to figure this one
out and just help me out companion mod
shader interactions possibly my only
guess is just with the companion
yes so the modern shader stuff I don't
use the companion app I use destiny had
a manager for everything because I don't
see anyway so I mean those guys hats off
to doom those guys crush it they have an
amazing little app their Google Chrome I
got my buttons in right here so I live
with that but I'm thinking it's just for
the communion companion app just either
on your phone or whatever so you can
move stuff around so hopefully just
moving between you know shaders or spots
or things like that or hopefully a
little more fluid that's my apps
absolutely sounds good I think you're
right spot on from that and then the
final thing for one point one point
three looks like the prestige nightfall
challenge cards so would you think about
that yeah we discussed it last time so I
mean it's nice to see that we've got
options of difficulty so if you want to
make it crazy hard like esoteric hats
off to him always you can and I mean if
he's gonna run through it in 10 minutes
burn through have an insanely high score
on the highest difficulty suite that's
gonna be an awesome thing to watch on
the other side you guys also be seeing
some solo nightfalls coming back because
I can take my time yes
you're not punished for going slowly but
you are rewarded for going quickly and I
like that balance absolutely no I'm just
gonna say shout out the Lord come back
to Leeds in the chat he's he he's uh
he's talking about the previous update
me a companion my stuff he's like wait I
can customize the shader he's an app he
can they can use a wardrobe feature
something like that and be one
especially at least on the website we
need to go in so it'd be nice to mess
around with that stuff absolutely man
and then like I say we got one point one
point for with the updates but uh are we
gonna go we're gonna deep dive with that
or we're gonna scroll down into the
update which one did we if you want to
discover the stuff that got moved I
think that's probably the no can biggest
pieces so it looks like arm basically
exotic reppin repetition reduction those
three at the bottom the ones that are
highlight those are what's moving I'm
confused here
or on the actual arm the actual roadmap
diagram itself so it look buff so before
and one point one point three it was it
said aura an emblem like rework
so those three bullet points were one so
we had a lot more pieces on February 27
right so everything from the 27th that
is now over on March 27th and sin yellow
with an asterisks was moved production
now it's thought that we've gotta wait
till March for that so don't die I'm
sorry Cadiz I'm gonna cut your sack so
if you were waiting for that one to come
in February you gotta wait another month
so bugs they're trying to fix or math
they're trying to check for drops and
things they've got to wait the big one
which we just talked about before we got
less so nightfall strike unique rewards
coming next not with the night boring so
as we said as we said you've got like
the big hype up nightfall scoring
tracking challenges and all those things
and then you've got the unique rewards
coming later yeah we talked about this
ad nauseam I mean that that's a problem
listen I'm trying to empathize with them
you know to get you know they being
transparent they're telling us it's
getting pushed back you know to that
March update and a March update we
already you know how excited I am about
that update you know but it just sucks
that you know next week the knife for
scoring is gonna be there and there's no
like you said cherry on the sundae
there's no unique reward to say boom I
did this we got the good score
you know we grind it out with my fire
team and it's like yay emblem I mean
that's all and the the emblems have them
some stuff too but it's like I mean come
on when I take out whoever the boss is I
want a piece of armor or a gun thrown
with them I want that I want that piece
that shows the be like hey I knocked out
the nightfall and now my gun looks
ridiculous because it's from the strike
or whatever it is so absolutely and to
be fair you know they did state you know
we get deep dive and scroll down like
you know that they want this thing to be
right at the weapons to be right they
wanted to be ultra cool and actually
liked that he said that that actually
made me feel a little better that he
said look we want these things to stand
out because currently as it stands a lot
of the grinding stuff that's currently
in place like the Iron Man on amnesty
you know faction rally on
they're okay but we really need like rat
to the Machine standout style stuff you
know I mean remember like you would like
I mean not a lot of people one of the
coolest things and we go well you know
what was that last update when we did
all the raids again and it was like the
final one what was fired I cannot even
remember the name remember well it was
almost like a love letter
they let us all the raids at higher
level and you know you remember getting
that vaulted glass set and it was just
boom and I mean that's a war like I have
a little Wi-Fi signal over my head you
wanna stand out man so if you like
they've got to get that together now
again I'm gonna try to give them a pass
and you understand because they did say
we want this to be cool and I respect
that but man it sucks February 27th that
we don't get the unique strikes rewards
with the night force records with the
scoring and tracking yeah it's like
we're getting half the plate we got her
steak but we didn't get her site up crab
macaroni to go with that's a personal
choice not a favorite meal so restaurant
down here my wife and I do for like
every six months for like big stuff and
good steaks and yeah that but they're
crab macaroni and cheese is oh like the
best like I hope compete so no it's it's
like getting half of it cuz if you want
it but you want to get rewarded with the
emblems okay but know what though I want
the real showing I want the when you
would see me walking around or I look at
my character I feel like a badass and
that's what we all want is to feel a
little bit more yeah a little bit more
like a legend like a you know absolutely
man so we're little saddened by that but
with which kind of trudge through but
you know Matt watch what he said looks
like when we getting that stuff and yeah
it looks like after that you know we go
except the exact repetition reduction I
got past that and I try and then the
companion vendor viewing so it looks
like you know I guess those absolute
just that's the United manager and all
that stuff
we'll be able to do vendors and things
like that so again it looks like they're
really doubling down on the companion
app stuff right yeah sometime I guess
that's I mean they probably have a team
for it so there's got to give them
something and try and make it
efficient as possible the last piece I
mean and what to end like March 27th
update may change - we just have to wait
and see but the big one that got pushed
a little bit as well is the exotic
weapon armor sandbox changes and she
there was a tweet didn't talk know what
I'm talking about
no talk to me educate oh there was a
tweet with regards to Sun shot and they
said they're doing testing with Sun shot
he and he had a triple kill from the
explosion and I'm sitting there going
that's the type of stuff I want to hear
but unfortunately it sounds like hey
that's too powerful of no no no that's
exactly what I want I want something
stupid like and then you can bring it
back but let house have stuff that's
kind of crazy like that sounds really
cool like if you get a head shot and
then you get a big explosion and you get
a triple kill from something that isn't
tuned quite right you know what that's
okay
that net is gonna be fun for a week or
two absolutely I I remember the tweet
and I was like wall in the Destiny
communities responded very positively
and so it's like yeah man when I hear
sonship I literally it got me so excited
I got sunshine out football in
preparation just get it ready I actually
play a little bit just you know with
such a gun like still probably a little
better just by power but SunShot has a
bad in PVE pvp it's not that great but
it's pretty good so I mean that's one I
know there's some that won't be touched
but there's hopefully a lot that will so
I'm hopeful that they they leave stuff
maybe not on a broken level but just a
hair below that and then you know it as
we as we want it I want stuff that's
exotic make it feel make those decisions
hard what is my exotic weapon I'm gonna
use mmm-hmm
you got stuff you're not gonna touch so
I want stuff that's you know a lot
better so absent we'll see what changes
between now and then but I mean
everything else is kind of as is the
sandbox update comes next the new season
expansion 2 and may all that stuff's
coming later but right now we got
nightfall scoring high score tracking so
let's jump down a little bit and get
into that a little bit more
so we've got the world of emblems so
this is what they were talking about
they had the destination emblem so
you've got your European dead zones so
devran k is gonna probably have his own
thing and you've got all the other
locations have theirs as well and those
could be something like hey how many
hive have you killed on Titan or
whatever it is something like that so
they want the emblems and destiny to be
positioned as a vanity collectible but
also to reflect noteworthy achievements
so to give them a little bit more a
little bit of customization and just a
little more that you can view about it
which is pretty cool to me personally so
you can see a little more track a little
more I like the idea of this I just wish
it was this and a record book because
this is cool public because yeah I was
like you could see this one and you
could check it out and be like hey this
person's you know killed way too many
people in crucible crap like I mean even
right here Dylan's
numbers if that's his or not that's a
lot so for that cuz I don't play that
much crucible but it'd be really cool to
have a book for yourself just to be able
to see all the tracking so hopefully
maybe you know come before taking King
2.0 whatever that's gonna that's just
what I call like destiny to to
absolutely do record book hopefully but
for now I kind of like it you can kind
of pick and choose what you want to brag
on but I mean if you're not a big
crucible person and you're a PvE person
there's hopefully stuff for you as well
absolutely they focus a lot on the
crucible in this one though so as you
can see so the victorious veterans this
is gonna be your details lifetime
crucible kills you can see each type of
crucible you know class that you killed
as well mmm cool even in the warlock has
been no no spoilers yet still 335 light
I'm waiting for one of these pics to
show up I'm sure to be like 355 what
exactly the length as long as that new
light level actually matters 350 or 4
million if it doesn't mean anything who
cares
so they said second we're collapsing
auras into emblems so that and they're
making them standalone items so your
auras from doing prestige nightfalls or
prestige raids or trials those are
actually going to come from the emblems
and usually going to be able to apply it
once you've hit a specific you know
whatever it is cool
so raid trials nightfall emblems you
guys can see it here the glory of the
emperor will apply an orange crown Orem
once you've cleared the prestige now I
don't know if that's because it shows
it's grayed out I don't know if this is
one or you still have to do it every
week like if you do the prestige
nightfall I can see that being a weekly
thing if you do the procedure aid let me
have the low aura like forever or
something I don't know first season
maybe I just like to see that one more
because once you do if it's a season and
maybe a clear and you're going for
something just the prestige rate I can
understand the knife all move trials
those could be a weekly thing because
there are weekly changes right I think
the rain would be nice because that's a
big it actually actually but then I'm
like the weight with the way you
explained it like you might me sell it
to me because a prestige rate is
something that is not you know dunno so
maybe that should stay for the season no
that's actually good I wouldn't be
opposed to that
yeah so these orders will come with
fireteam bonuses as well so if you see
an aura you know who's giving you the
benefit of they said more tokens or
engrams or something who knows what the
bonuses are gonna be and then they say
lastly they introduced they want to
introduce what variants what state which
is cool so again they're putting a whole
lot of emphasis on emblems which is you
know a cosmetic nameplate which I know
it's like you know if this was just in
there at the start of Destiny one it'd
be cool like they're adding it now and
putting a lot of emphasis on this I
don't mind the deep dive is we have
stuff to talk about but in general this
stuff if it was at the beginning little
too late for some but we still enjoy it
so variants they've got you can see here
if you're going for crucible kills say
if you kill a thousand Titans so you can
see now the variant changes with the
logo of the Titan in the hunter or the
world on the last
mm-hmm actually see it's like the broken
logo versus the standard logo maybe yes
class or whatever and that's pretty cool
if you're like hey you know what I'm
coming for and you're like if you're
warlock and you got killed by somebody
with the broken world like they're like
Danny they just hunt warlocks or what a
little bit of that little poke in the
bear we needed just to kind of get you
more invested emotionally get in support
your class a little bit be like hey I'm
a hunter I'm not killing my own sorry
warlocks you're going down officially
just delete it's nice to see stuff like
this and I hope there's a lot more of it
again emblems I wish it was something
that was actually like maybe hovering
over your head to when you're running
around so you could actually see it as
opposed to just the loading screen or
the kill screen if it was just even just
a little icon up there the broken symbol
was next to my name when I'm running
around in the world that my present just
whatever your you know feel like
wrapping at the time yeah I actually
like that and again I mean talk like I
said if they care like maybe some little
visual representation in conjunction
with this that'd be great but again all
this stuff really helps you get more
invested in the crews one again I'm all
about them doing things with a crucible
right now because I'm you know getting
wrong PvE status issues too but crucible
that's so far behind and they need these
type of things to get emotional
engagement in crucible you got to get
people excited about crucible yeah
that's a must
so I mean it's gonna be these are a
little baby steps so but yeah but for
the people who want to have some fun
with it and I kind of like it so they
say other drops are sources like
destination chests or night falls and
they some of them might be quite rare so
some of the emblem changes may be
something where maybe you do every
adventure on a planet you go talk to
Debra Kay and he gives you a specific
alternate for the European dead zone in
bloom so it's just something like that's
a guest I have no idea what the
destinations are gonna be if it's just
the ranking maybe you get a different
one as you get up to rank 10 or maybe
it's do a certain thing on the planet
what uh kind of wait and see I guess
yeah shout out to uh chief copy to
chatty saying that if they did
stealing a cult seal demon wolf a three
type of emblems with the animations and
stuff like that I mean it'll get a
little bit more in there become awesome
yeah yeah and no chief Tommy crucible
does not have more than two modes just
yet they work - got it especially when
it's like Monday through or yeah Tuesday
through Thursday you're just sitting
there with quick play and yeah
competitive it's like so but they did
say and I feel like I've glanced over it
yeah yeah is it well get well look if
you don't look what will get we don't
save that though cheat time because we
couldn't get to they are going to expand
it and we will tell you good variants
are coming which is pretty cool down
here we've got the nightfall emblem so
this is your PvE side of things so this
is what the strikes warrant comes into
play you can see your personal score the
bonus threshold so if you get above a
certain amount that's where you're gonna
get your crown your purple crown so and
they said they're gonna determine that
based on kind of internal testing at the
start so I'm gonna you know they had
certain people testing this way and this
way and then you know a few of us go
through we just blow it away they might
book that threshold up the next time it
comes back so we're just gonna have to
see at first if you're going for
something to look pretty you might try
at the first round because if those
scores go up a little bit might be a
little harder to get right later on but
they said they expect some of them to be
quite rare so maybe there's maybe
there's a threshold beyond just the
basic one where you get something even
cooler or maybe that's something that
can add it later with challenge cards
version - yeah absolutely
cool direction you know I like my aura
know I've always been a fan of the aura
I was very sad when he got rid of it no
so finally brought it back - brought it
back auras is good I want to shine I
mean I want that light on me I did the
nightfall and then they say bonus
Vanguard token drops I'm kind of like
May
I mean Vanguard opens like I mean I
think this have always given us all 14
of everything at this point for as many
a cool thing would be like hey if all
your party has you know the purple aura
on maybe you get an extra in gram or a
bonus give it a little more incentive to
maybe run it more than once
yeah good point good point absolutely
yeah strike specific rewards for the day
[ __ ]
and that counts and that comes right in
here too so maybe a higher chance at the
strike specific rewards if you have the
aura on or maybe they're working on it I
don't know but that would give you
incentive to be like hey run it this
week score was you know okay there but
you know it's got this badass gun go for
it one more time let's even just rerun
this thing we already know this dress
and go for it again you just took me to
a place you literally took me as a great
idea you took me to I'm Nicole screaming
[ __ ] and you took me to grinding for
pulse or as a grasp of melon yeah and
it's like could you imagine if we had
like this emblem that kind of increase
the chances once you you know ran it as
a night fall yeah you know that what I
did have it where chances will increase
is creased if it was the night fall but
now it like if the emblem kind of acts
in that fashion and increases the drop
rate even more they give you that
incentive like you said just what you
wanted yeah I need that specific you
know knife for a weapon or when I felt a
piece of armor from set boss yeah and
and I honestly when it comes to the
rewards the armor is so lackluster right
now yeah if I get a piece of armor again
it's like it's another paint job it's
another skin yeah I would much rather
see we only have six strikes basically
mm-hmm if I feel like yeah we've got a
couple more with the expansion out we've
only got so many so when you bring in
like I'd rather see a gun of each type
from each place because the guns at
least you can have some fun
gives them one cooler perk so yeah
there's something you want cuz effective
armor there's three weeks out of you
know every six or seven where you're
like I don't care about the armor it's
not great I agree completely that's a
whole different problem with armor and
we've covered that before no shadow
document easily we've got to the loot
problem but yeah that pretty much covers
most of this I know there's a piece
about the crucible so I've got to look
for that here in a second they do have
you know a patch coming out on Tuesday
so this will be the pad
only a couple hours actually shorter
than usual for downtime which is nice
come home on Tuesday it's like it goes
down at 10:00 I've gotta wait for hours
I'm like well I'm gonna go
I don't know work out and then take a
nap I'm not sure but got some time
usually two hours I'm happy it's shorter
so just make sure you guys get that
patch going as soon as you can so you
can get back on a couple preview things
for the patch so they said they'd fix an
issue where the Phoenix dive for the
warlocks is going to get you out of the
intended play space so you know not
breaking the game always a good thing
nice nice
fixed an issue where players could
receive a loss in trials if opponents
leave multiple matches in a row it's
good like the more stuff they can I
think that's one of the biggest thing
even destined said it before he's like I
stopped doing trials when I got to you
know six wins and somebody disconnected
and then we lost and you're just like
there needs to be some things that
detects be like hey somebody left there
was a disconnect at any point if that
happens and call it null and void and
just call him out to be like hey it's a
draw nothing happens and come back for a
full match just that I know it's not an
easy programming fix they would have
done it already but that just that level
of if anything happens call it like and
I mean that would be a way for people to
have at least incentive I mean people
would probably be disconnecting all the
time if they got a loss or something
which kind of sucks but I don't know the
more people to go to the lighthouse the
more people who'd probably play it so at
this point make it a little bit to where
you know people don't get quite as
screwed would probably help over a
little bit yeah actually I would I think
we forgot one thing if you scroll back
all the way up to the top with the
roadmap if you click the development
destiny to development role meant like
shadow to achieve Tommy because he's
asking me in the chat you know what
about all the crucible bones like the
mayhem and stuff like that and the like
all 6v6 so if you scroll back up you
should see the destitute development
roadmap font kind of highlighted in
yellow you know take us to a link I just
want to show chief Tommy that because
they actually scroll down a little bit
they're gonna have a a weekly what you
call it uh yeah they're right there but
actually above us I'm sorry it was it
was actually above right case yeah
destiny - development roadmap the fonts
no yeah click that for a second so um
yeah if you scroll down here this is
what a dev team was talking about and
then they will also scroll a little
they were also talking about um actually
it's not there I know I'm trying to I
know exactly what you know what I'm yeah
so I mean basically the idea is they're
they're gonna bring back playlists so
they've mentioned that somewhere and
actually I kind of have an idea where
this is that yeah yeah it's almost back
to that weekly playlist that we missed
man for crucian here yeah so they also
have a big addition we're here to share
so we'll be joining 6v6
iron banner and may him in our new
rotating weekly crucible playlist again
one point one point four or so that's
the Marshall he setups nice they want to
make sure players have more diverse set
of game modes available in both crucible
and private matches which private
matches aren't even coming yet but they
even said that it's not in one point
also planning to make a return so people
did enjoy that one so it's kind of cool
but we do not have an exact release date
yet for dice as always keep an eye out
but I thought it was cool Rumble will be
joining 6v6
iron banner and mayhem and I remember
hot listen I had so much fun that was
like my highlight for the dawning
man-made it was so much fun didn't have
a 6v6 playlist and again that Weekly
rotating you know list so you know but
right now we have as soon as the reset
has when we have our flash point we have
caller arms we have arm you know your
basic you know raid stuff but yeah yeah
yeah but I always felt crucible needed
another mold besides just called arms
and because the modes were limited with
just competitive and you know whatever
quick play now you throw this weekly
rotating us that's d1 remember our
little icons in the lower left corner I
did the daily crucible I did dads that
engagement in crucible needed it's so
bad and then the next step I'm gonna
push for them I want that true meaning
of war like hardcore crucible that like
less than trials but for that guy who's
committed you know you get remember how
it was it was like 100 shotgun kills or
you get whatever it forced you to play
different ways you know to get that and
you got exotic level rewards from shacks
so again this is the right direction I
just want the
keep pushing but there you go cheap down
I need to get you we know it was in
there and I knew I read it I just this
was on the other page so I mean they're
gonna bring them back so it's just nice
to see you we're gonna have an option so
66 seems like it's sound continue to
sounds like it's just gonna be iron
banner which maybe that's their way to
make iron banner distinct kind of cool
may him yeah just had a ton of fun so
that should be in there as much as
possible and Rumble well honestly this
is the modem most curious about cuz this
will get a feel for what's broken and
what's not because you're not just doing
team shooting mm-hmm you're finally
gonna get a feel for hey if I run into a
one-on-one yeah I may get the first shot
but you know if somebody's got a better
gun will they out shoot me I don't know
I'm looking forward to rumble because
while I wasn't ever I was somewhere in
the middle I usually be like 2 or 3 ya
know or haven't always first but I could
usually kind of hold my own to be
somewhere in the middle and it was
always fun to just honestly see how you
manage us one-on-one engagements and in
that way it won't be just team shot at
all Amen house you run free to do your
thing you know you know you your own
mercenary like again let's enforce that
you have to stick next to a teammate I
can do my own thing for the solo players
out there you know absolutely one other
piece they mentioned so as they said
before they want to take some time to
make sure the nightfall rewards and
we're giving them a little bit it's fine
they just want to make sure the artists
have time to make sure the rewards are
super cool they use that word literally
twice so they want to make sure they're
cool so hopefully they are if they step
it up and we like them and you know I
want my head to be glowing some
ridiculous crazy color whatever I might
like make it ridiculous and I'm fine
with that but they also did say which is
kind of kind of disheartening but it's
one of those again do it right it's fine
if it's later because you're not gonna
win people back until you have a lot of
things correct so they said the mod
system will not be available with 1.2 so
it is not coming with maze season 3 now
I don't know if that's like just a delay
to the extension or what but it's not
coming at least in this roadmap as of
now it may be one of those fall
improvements if you want to put that in
quotes in your head yeah yeah I mean
that's a little
that's interesting
relaunch it better with with mods 2.0 is
that what they're basically gonna go
like I mean Diablo was loot 2.0 is this
gonna be loot and mods 2.0 hopefully for
whatever the fall big expansion is yeah
I mean it's gonna be interesting Hamlet
because the loot problem like shut up
the you know talking usually I was on
the show that's the big one
so mods help that issue and um you know
but not having that so late oof let's
this is a tough one this is this is a
tough pill spot to see how they handle
become put it put it this way mods to
what has to be amazing oh it does now it
has to be a big people want that you
those unique roles they want that you
know they want that thing to chase that
what mean you know the crime for the
make it unique to make it their own and
that I thought was gonna be their way of
maybe this my guess was like myotube
when I was gonna be like extra perk
slots right because D one member our
weapons had multiple perks locks
alright a multiple configuration so it's
a more options to be like hey I want to
add range
I don't had to range to this auto rifle
so I've got a lot of use out of it oh
yeah because I feel better everything
else I'm stability honest count like
yeah give us multiple options let us
pick let us let it you if they want to
have set rolls let us be the ones who
customized that just absolutely multiple
slots oh now let me ask you this a mods
to point no did come with season 3 does
that take the gravity does that take the
weight out of what could be expansion
big major expansion in the fall if they
have big expansion mods 2.0 loot 2.0 is
that one of those major bullet points
that isn't easy a bigger seller I think
so I think that could be part of the
idea to be like hey this is something
that so many people are asking about if
we do it right let's do it when it's big
yeah but see my thing is again let's
let's backtrack the timing of it is it
going to be like that September like I'm
kind of taking King Tiger II is it going
to be in conjunction with that I mean I
it better be if it's not if it's not
that's what I'm saying like if it is
with that you know taking King 2.0 P at
September I don't care if it's December
if it's done right but it's probably
September that's just destiny - yep if
it's with that one it may be a bigger
selling point as opposed to in an
expansion for you know yeah but I was
like trust me me I want it sooner than
later but it may be a bigger selling
point for the next thing which is I
agree I agree I think I think it's I
think you nailed it I think it's
literally what they're doing is they're
taking more time with it they know
they're taking King style it's an
expansion instead it's it's really
rotted I at that point you know because
III will have passed they will have
announced it it's coming September
before the November game stuff like that
that's their last chance in my opinion
if collectively bring people back and
you've got it knock it out the park so
you figure like the Ebru promotion all
that stuff for the trailer for whatever
this is most likely what you guessing
like savathun right or some type of
thing like that and you know fibers
floating out there in the world or that
most likely it'll be too high field if
history repeats itself
yeah I was pretty lackluster in this you
know and rightfully so they had their
shining d1 you know so I just stood the
direction character-wise of lore wise
but yeah I mean if they're gonna sell
that expansion you know what better way
to sell you know that randomized them
you know that that loot that you know
that grinding loot that you know all the
stuff that people have you know like
Dokken eating and in a community that
fall off that's what they want they want
random rolls again they want all that
stuff so and maybe it sucks for us that
still plated we have to wait it's like
alright fine I mean all of these little
things are like good at pieces it's like
adding and adding your rolling snowball
down the hill it's getting bigger and
bigger and then hopefully finally when
you get to the bottom and it smashes
into something you explode taking tube
or you know and go we but until then
yeah it kinda hurts I agree
so we will have to see on that one I
will go back to where we were though but
yeah that's most of it we've got the
auras come in we've got the
Crucible variants those things are I
mean it's nice to see those things we
don't have the like or the glory or the
Valor like the PvP unless those are just
subtly in there but I don't think they
mentioned that stuff yet the ranking
system yet for PvP that one's not in
there yet so I don't actually know where
that one is on the map so with ranking
for PvP I don't even see it in there so
sometime later but for now that's kind
of most of it I think yeah yes what we
get for the table for the most part and
then um wanted to talk real quickly well
first of all just like overall what
would you feel about this table and you
know in general and about the the
overall you know edits to the
development map yeah I mean for me I'm
looking forward to the night while
scoring I mean the timer I never felt
was like it as I've heard a couple
different people say different podcasts
and things it's like the timer wasn't
bad if I had three people with me it
wasn't ever bad but after a while it
just kind of got to be you know it
wasn't it kind of sucked some of the fun
of it cuz again you would rush there as
fast as possible just trying to finish
it I don't know how they're gonna fix
the Rat King quest they have to adjust
that now though yeah that's true so that
one's gonna have to get some exotic
quest adjustment so that's got to be in
there but I mean outside of that I'm
looking forward to it because for me it
lets me do my nightfall solo videos
people have asked me about that for six
months and I'm happy to bring it back to
them so that piece I'm happy about the
rewards not being there as kind as you
said it's the sundae without the whipped
cream and cherry on top where we're
missing the incentive to go with the fun
part so I'm kind of you know again as I
said snowball started rolling this is a
couple things on there the emblems maybe
cool and we'll see what comes next but
for me it's you know um I'm somewhat
optimistic in in the slightest of ways
what my overall thoughts or season for
the expansion of season 3 in May or
whatever and then just some mention of
what e3 is so all this stuff in between
now and then is smaller yeah absolutely
absolutely and for me like nothing
really changes for me I think for me
outside of the knife for specific um you
know loot not being there
you know for February 27 you know I'm
saying but ultimately for me I've always
like I had my heart on March 27 that
sandbox change that you know aren't you
notice i'm bannin 6v6 weekly crucible
stuff you know that is gonna get me
really to get excited to at least start
playing more consistently you know right
now I know you you're a monster hunter I
want Kingdom Come deliverance amongst
other games you know and I'm I want to
get back to the daily touching of
destiny
you know consistently again and I think
for me it starts for me personally it
starts with the daily crucible getting
me into that getting those you know
sandbox changes in their nobility
changes and modifies and the unique
rewards that's how you get me in slow
you know I mean and then you know we got
season three and then obviously the big
one come down the road yes and that's
kind of thing too it's like I wonder cuz
you used to have you know you do the
bounty or something if you did the big
one you got you no chance at a gun it
was always a chance that a random role
though yes back to even like you know if
I have the crucible weapons what I'm you
know if you have the twelve that are out
there there's no incentive to good point
so I mean though I don't know how so
many more things but yeah that's a
discussion for another day but just play
in that seat in year do you guys have
thoughts always throw them down in the
comments and the videos and anything
like that so we're always curious to
hear what you guys think but absolutely
general it's you know they've started
the baby steps in the right direction
and there's no question they're working
like there's a lot they've got on the
books so absolutely we know that so
before we wrap up why don't we got the
little job posting that we saw I think I
caught a blip of this but somebody
basically said they're looking for a
head of narrative development so come on
let's let's hear it yeah I mean
basically you know last year I believe
well maybe it was it wasn't last year
yeah but I'll say maybe was two years
ago and I remember doing an old-school
aisle patient I have to like Luis Laden
was there
and our Lord addict we're doing this and
then like we will hike ahead of
narrative development this this position
always seems to be open you know I guess
a reason why I want to bring it you know
the flashpoint was just from the
standpoint of um obviously it looks like
they're looking for you know an
experienced director you know that he's
gonna be a management position promoting
and you know fostering excellence blah
blah blah and then you know
responsibilities are going to be promote
teamwork and healthy collaboration
studio wide in collaboration with the
project leads and the VP game
development organizing structure the
narrative team to best support these
studio you know so pretty much a lot of
day-to-day stuff and I'm a little
concerned only for the simple fact that
all right well actually I'm happy and
I'm concerned I'm happy because we all
know curse of Osiris story little boy
you know and I was in comics had more
going on than we go thank you
yeah in the comic that's a problem and
it's so confusing to me Montes because
you know let's be real like the destiny
to story for the most part what gall was
good right it was kind of like question
mark but yes yes overall yeah I mean the
story the act not acting the voice
acting for you know like the speaker and
gall and his I can't remember the dude's
name was the terrible face oh yeah yeah
but I mean just like let me I I mean I
enjoyed it it was it amazing no it
wasn't like a Mass Effect story but it
was definitely by far the best for
destiny a pretty solid for a shooter at
the grand scheme of things so it's
getting back to what Bungie needs but
again then you have curso Osiris you
know like what happened and it just it
goes to show me the dysfunction and as
far as narrative and you know I pray for
the boy Lord wife you know I know by
face you'll see these kind of things if
I get some say it's just so strange to
me that it's like they can't seem to
either consistently get the narrative
together and I thought would be to that
actually had confidence coming into
cursors I don't know
the last thing I thought that the story
was gonna be the products I'm like okay
they got that down does need to prove
that they can get a solid story out
they're back on it and then you know we
really had this you know they really
kind of fell back it was it was just
kind of like them slipping back into
their own ways and we're like what
happened you know so when I see this I'm
just like okay they they're recognized
I'm happy that they're recognizing they
still need help here but it's just like
what's going on you know that that this
position seems to always kind of
reappear in Papa's head back up yeah I
mean it's one of those you wonder when
it comes to just a story in general how
every time we get an expansion it always
feels like just me one you had you know
the overall vex which even the raid
seemed disconnected substantially from
just the overall story yes so just the
vault of glass didn't have that
connection I want like things to connect
I want to ask I want a big arc for if
like Destiny's season what like season
one or year one of destiny two should be
the overall arc of ghul like don't wrap
it I mean you got to more like give me I
mean yeah you have the Leviathan raid
sitting out there and that's fine but
have a year's worth of a story planned
out and have the expansions build on
that not just be a random vex offshoot
for Osiris mm-hmm
build more of biggest thing about TV
shows for me sorry for the no go for a
go for it but the biggest thing about TV
shows for me is usually not the day to
day even if it's when it's like say it's
a procedural it's like me and my wife
have watched Castle just one of those
shows Nathan feeling and shout out oh
it's me it's like the day-to-day
episodes I could you know basically you
know chill in my phone probably most
play a game in the background to get the
gist it's the overall arcs that always
get me every time yes these are long
arcs be a game of Thrones whatever show
it is it's the bigger arcs that always
have more gravitas and more weight to
them and those are the ones I want more
not just like here's your missions and
you're done it's like hey here's this
you know with Gaul yeah quite get him he
runs off in a ship you know and he'll be
back in septic in December have a
cliffhanger on a story yes it's all
incentive to come back to be like hey
what the hell happens next then finally
maybe give yourself more time for a may
expansion
that'd be what wraps it up be like hey
you guys finally got ahold of Gul well
guess what we've got a whole new that
you're coming for you I mean that's the
that's the bill that one mm-hmm
absolutely and I think that that has to
happen at that and they've shown flashes
like you know when you end you know
obviously spoilers for indie destiny too
by now but you know when you end it it
was just like okay is this an extra
alien race not at the traveler you know
release that energy like what who's that
hunting or sparking like it started
those question it was so exciting to
talk about that kind of stuff and then
it's like we literally got none of that
at the end of her solo Cyrus it was just
like okay I'm going back inside you're
just like left with old your jaw like my
Twitter background my proof I'm a
disciple of Osiris like I've I've waited
for you all the know who you are all
this stuff we got so little expertise I
probably learned more about brother
Vance yep then I did and now they made
him just a crew be like that very
religious prophetic figure to like
groupies daddies you know saying that
for a Cyrus but whatever like you have
something to wear like maybe the flash
points on mercury be like a Osiris is
back in the tower he's got some quest
for you like infinite forest I don't
know what more that's all I wanted more
exact and his other disappointment was
like I thought at the bare minimum I
would get Osiris as a permanent NPC on
Mercury yeah you don't mean like it's
like yeah you're going to do your thing
but you know it's an NPC you're still
gonna be chillin in the tower and maybe
he has other stuff first interact with
and you level up with him and maybe
there's part yes absolutely it's like
how does he just walk out and you're
like the dude we've been waiting on for
three years like literally three years
and see ya Oh super super lame and again
I'm happy that they're recognizing
that's a problem they need help and it's
just again it is very it was just the
cursed Osiris he showed me like they are
still
dysfunctional no because you have unless
someone you know can tell me that that's
this my gut feeling tells me that that's
that not the same team that did the
destiny to base game story no I mean I
can't believe that but my worry about
this is they're looking now how far out
do you think this position is dealing
with because you're looking at like a
September release and you're just hiring
somebody now yeah you're gonna oversee
it what does it feel rushed again or
this or something later I mean so I know
some things have to be in the works but
if they're looking for this help now you
have to wonder what the story's gonna be
like for something that's basically
probably already submitted and being
finalized in May you've got you know a
couple patches whatever's there that
one's already done there's that one's
not going to be rewritten otherwise
those people are probably going to you
know work until their feet fall off but
I mean generally it's like what what is
this does this make you I was like it
makes me apprehensive to wonder what we
have for future story if this is what's
building they may be adding to a team so
they can do more but again it still
makes me wonder as this is a a lead and
a manager like where where are we right
now with what right it's scary because I
mean look at the required skills it's
like a deep desire to focus in
management and story strategy with the
game narrative and storytelling
disciplines affect the experience and
effectively managing personal you should
apply for this by the way I should
literally just for this was really
really need leadership like what is
going on man you know and again you know
it's just one of those you know one step
forward two step back I think it's just
it does concern me like I said I'm gonna
try to stay positive and say hey they're
recognizing but they really gotta come
especially with this upcoming one coming
the young yeah what does it do and a
brave awfully warm iron slash I know
it's gonna be exactly what we're talking
about it's just another random offshoot
or does this tie into anything any yes
you know and that it shout out to my boy
you know
this is what his issue is cuz if you
think if he put it this way if the
Leviathan eater of worlds ready I'm
connected narrative Li to curse of
Osiris he would have been invested he's
just like why am I going to apartment 2c
and the Leviathan raid yeah understand
it's like there's no exposition as to
why we have to go back there's no
nothing it's no reason and it should
have been expected or at the very least
osiris should have been like look you
know this is the next step or the next
thing I'm just you into it give me I'll
give you a connection too and again that
was kind of the thing about the rape
watch point is probably long I had we
tried but no seriously like when you
finish up the story it's kind of like
okay and I know they have the wait in
like literal days or three or four days
till the raid comes out but have the end
of the story not wrap up and be like
okay we're on the tower chillin wait in
the tower chillin for three days of the
ship showed up like like put something
in the story to explain that as opposed
to one random adventure 95% of the
people did not see I mean that's the
same thing as you said either world to
be like hey Kris over Cyrus it's like
hey I know the VEX is over here one of
their weird connections like go through
the infinite forest what if you had to
go through the infinite forest actually
get into eater of worlds yeah what if
that was your way to then that's one of
their things and it looks like the
Leviathan still but that's one of their
other simulations or something like that
and that's your raid and you just enter
it through mercury is supposed to go in
the hole oh my iPhone yeah you know
what's funny they started off so well it
destiny too because I remember you know
like okay great story we gotta figure
out what's going on up there and then
like they even had like a little sin
maduk right before you start the rain
I'm like okay this is that we've always
I was so hyped for that I'm like okay
and then here come Christmas Harrison
either world's none of that no cinema no
nothing no there's not even a map
indicator to say hey you got to go here
next no there's yeah there's no no heads
up oh by the way this is over here you
should probably take a look at this like
it's like the overall arcs but ya have
pieces have the game connects all the
pieces that's that's got to be a must
for going forward because a few I mean
whatever so if it's if some reason the
war mind has and then your rate layer is
gonna be over there and it's like is it
because the raid team can you reuse art
assets but you look at the end of the
worlds it's not even the same like you
go in the tunnel but it doesn't even
look remotely similar I mean back flip
sighs so why is it have to be tied there
it's like I will I will make a
confession avanti's I will be cyber
stalking whoever this announced
personally was I get that Twitter handle
of who this better they will be getting
tweets from me lead your like questions
exact because I need answers I need and
shout out to you know CJ Barrett you
know these guys you know they he's been
super transparent now that you know
they're in the community manager you
know and they're letting us talk to them
directly and I see them you know they
may even watch flashpoint which to them
now we really appreciate it you know
this is obviously a passion project but
um yeah man like I really want to talk
to these guys just want to know what my
thing is explain to us the thought
process you know of these DLCs being
these separate little pockets that seem
disconnected from everything yeah it's
like is it is there a program thing is
that the system's things where they
don't connect but some way to make as
you said if they're disconnected you
take away from your incentive like
seasons of TV do it movies do it for
cliffhangers Marvel's the master it you
know stingers at the end but you gave me
no clue what the hell are we
it could be you know destiny three if
that's the little triangle ships but if
that's what it is that's what it is yeah
I was like that's fine but tell me but
also be like hey curse of Osiris is
coming and you know it's three months
out you have to have some assets in
there have a trailer team just build
something up and do like hey this is
what's coming and I know some stuff is
in you know floating you have to don't
certainly the details but like yeah some
way to connect the two and as you said
that's the biggest thing is have the
reins connect when you talk about crota
everybody hates that expansion but that
raid all connected with hive was one of
the better ones yes I know the raid was
like kind of broken at times and
unplugging kneeling and those are all
fun narrative wise why is it made sense
any sense
took from that even though the crota
taken key that realm that's more of what
I want yes that if you have that type of
connection then and said hey we killed a
son dad's pissed words but that's it
like everybody can understand you killed
my son my progeny yeah yeah I'm taking
up the whole solar system now exactly
end of the story remember you had a
little cinematic with Eris and the
holistic realm and the she's picking up
a sword and like it led you on it it's
not over the campaign for the tinking we
still gotta finish the job there's
something else going on and it will mean
yeah I mean it's we didn't get to fight
Gaul in the raid which would have made
more sense even we get to fight a robot
for one but yeah the weird you know
pleasure-garden dude yeah overall if
that's like I don't know who's in charge
of those pieces of all of destiny's
content where that's how that story
needs to foil so amen so that's what I
got to yeah I'm with you man like 20
minutes and then our flashpoint is no
longer short shout-out to the world of
Bungie like all of you guys over there
I cannot literally imagine how much you
guys are killing yourselves
I know it's there's no question when it
comes to game development you hear about
crunch time i t anything like that I
mean you want to talk about like
development and sprints and things these
are development terms that some people
are huh yep
just all of those things they're on a
whole different level there there's like
waterfall agile and basically just go
into the head combined like they have to
just like go they have so much that they
have to do and I'm just hoping this
one's had enough time to get developed
but I'm very curious what's to come but
they're trying to kick their they have
so much intertwined systems that are
touching each other yeah absolutely
so it's like for the things that they
want to change it's not an easy task so
they're trying
I love the transparency just shout out
to all those guys over there we can
never come hang out for a day love it
just to ask questions
I can leave tape recorders I don't care
yeah just to be like awesome guys you
know kind of just a couple hundred
questions yeah shout out to those guys I
mean like I said as much as we complain
as much as we you know this is something
we want to improve you know we do
understand that how systems are
connected and from development you know
the changes that we want like you said
could affect other things I got a chance
to sit down would be each our own beach
beach last year and um you know really
cool god I just told him I was like - I
know I would it be kind of like you have
to though be like hey CJ Barret I think
your Twitter's probably exploded you may
not even enjoy responding you do which
you know had taken the time to do it
this and like you'll respond to the
constructive ones which is logical
you're not gonna listen to every day you
know Torme on the internet but just the
time that they spend dealing with a crap
storm coming their way I mean they
handle it well I mean they have to I
mean that's got to be literally
somewhere in any of these job required
skills next bullet point add below
ability to handle crap coming your way
all the time right in their defense
you know a company could easily I've
seen it before with other companies you
know they sold a lot they make their
money and they don't go back to the game
to change anything like it's like we got
your money you know that kind of thing
so I gotta give them some credit at
least it you know with the transparently
see with them changing things like you
said almost on the fly and trying to get
this thing back on the right track you
know so you know shout-out to those guys
we still gonna be on you
what happens all about flashpoint is
back to Long Point yeah once again I
can't even look at the time you'd have
to tell me but yeah it's uh yeah well
this one will go up guys of course leave
comments on that you know iron Lawrence
podcast subscribe their iPod kiss on my
channel will have it up on both follow
us on Twitter as well we always like to
keep you guys entertained with random
goofy gifts or whatever comes our
destiny news way in general because it's
a game if this one doesn't do it for you
we'll let you know when to come back
wins the wins the big one
March seems like a good one we're
kognito we'll probably be like our I
might lose a couple days back in the
crucible again feel and everything else
but I've got a little calendar baby I'm
gonna leave work early and take the next
day off it's fine wrap it up give them
your outro and I'll do mine let's do
this thing
lower kognito of the iron Lords podcast
please follow me on Twitter at Lord
Cognito remember every Sunday at 1 p.m.
Eastern on the inner circle Network
channel that's when it is the Lord's Day
I lost podcast we'll go live with those
other crazy Lords looking look sovereign
their Lord addict you know we should
have a special guest this week I'll get
the table so please follow the iron Lord
podcast Twitter as well and we also have
some stuff up there and uh like these
flash points man I know these don't get
a lot of use a lot of people have gone
away from destiny but we do appreciate
this but we do get we know this is a
hardcore deep-dive passion project
between me and boxes and we just love
doing it man and we will continue to do
as long as you guys like it and we're
still clear to do it anyway cuz we like
yeah it's like destiny is just part of
my soul at this point so I have ours on
your magical 10,000 hour mark mate so
we'll keep going for me you bonta's as
well pretty much everywhere if you guys
are watching this on Twitch sorry I
haven't been responding to comments but
I can't see him right now so forgive me
but yeah twitch.tv slash bonta's Twitter
you bought this there as well and right
here on youtube if you guys are watching
it there hit that subscribe button leave
a like if you guys enjoy these things
we do do it for you guys and we do it
just because honestly sometimes good to
just you know let up let it all out for
a week give you no thoughts here and
there you read these things you want to
get some stuff out and flashpoints
turned into long points and that just
how that goes Louis guys hit the
subscribe buttons on both of the
channels wherever you guys are at I was
like let's all wrap it as I do on my
videos good afternoon good morning or
good evening where have you guys are
watching this whenever you guys are
watching this have a good one please